et nous allons revenir sur cette
interview d'eric zemmour bâtisse que
vous êtes à côté de moi on va commencer
par bourbon jours ci bonjour merci
beaucoup de nous avoir rejoints bonjour
benjamin morel merci d'être là comme
tous les mercredis et
merci également d'être avec nous d'abord
un mot général puisque vous avez
évidemment écouté attentivement cette
interview qu'est ce que vous en avez
pensé yves
bony thériault je pense que si vous
voulez il ya deux choses la première
réflexion que m'inspire cette longue
induce a duré une heure quand même c'est
que
eric zemmour va dans le fond des sujets
et à
révèle une certaine forme de pragmatisme
à travers ce genre d'interview ce qu'on
n'a pas l'habitude de l'entendre sur
l'industrie de l'entendre sur la
désertification de la france de
l'ensemble sur ces sujets là et je
trouve que ces réponses sont pleines de
bon sens c'est qu'il est assez
pragmatique et je crois que là il peut
rencontrer un public et un électorat
nombreux
mais mais qu'est ce qui va se passer
c'est que lyn thériault qui vous est
accordée elle va être complètement entre
guillemets si je puis me permettre
écrasé par la réflexion qu'il a eu sur
la délinquance en disant que les tous
les étrangers sont des délinquants en
gros c'est ce qu'il a dit est évidemment
que le milliard en sont des étrangers il
était exactement et évidemment les
médias vont retenir cette cette formule
est le problème c'est que l'on peut pas
réduire jeu j'estime qu'on ne peut pas
réduire la réflexion et la candidature
de eric zemmour à cela mais
malheureusement c'est ce qui risque de
se produire oui je suis fondamentalement
d'accord en réalité là c'est sans doute
une erreur de communication parce que
cette interview elle montrait malgré
tout une capacité de rebondir sur des
sujets différents l'analyste qui l'a
fait devant vous des sujets relatifs à
la décentralisation relatifs à
l'industrie relatifs à l'écologie on en
pense qu'on en veut d'un point de vue
idéologique du point de vue du
positionnement politique mais vous avez
aujourd'hui une construction sur cette
thématique et on lui a longtemps
reproché d'être monothématique le
problème c'est que lorsque vous
diversifiez vos thématiques mais que
vous lancez une bombe que l'on ne va que
l'on ne va que retenir en réalité est
bien tout d'un coup vous redonnez flanc
à la critique
être à la fois extrêmement caricaturale
et monothématique c'est un peu dommage
qu'il ait fait ça ce matin pour lui mais
il assume finalement ça oui ils assurent
le bien et il n'ya pas il a répété être
deux pas de yahia pas de nouveautés je
dirais puisqu'il l'a dit plusieurs fois
et ça c'est la lutte beaucoup émiratie
il ya beaucoup d'élus et bon français
qui gagnerait d'aller visiter certaines
prisons comme moi je le fais assez
régulièrement dans le cadre de mon
métier et vous allez à fleury mérogis
vous allez dans les grandes
dans les grands centres
pénitentiaires qui sont à la fois des
centrales et des maisons d'arrêt et vous
vous apercevez de la population qui est
là aussi bien d'ailleurs dans les
départements féminin que masculin les
départements féminin par exemple son
plein et rempli deux ressortissantes de
d'amérique latine qui sont là pris dans
des réseaux de drogue et qui sont
condamnés à des peines de prison et vous
allez dans l'est dans les départements
masculin et là vous avez et bien une
population qui est en grande partie
évidemment
étrangères laiteries sont pas seulement
étrangers immigrés enfants d'immigrés ou
enfants d'immigrés ce qui veut dire
qu'ils peuvent être français mes enfants
du mouvement c'est ce qu'il va l'écouter
réellement justement et on va réagir sur
cet extrait
immigration c'est la mère de toutes les
batailles c'est pour ça que nous avons
une délinquance aussi explosif c'est à
cause de l'immigration donc si on
arrêtait l'immigration immigration zéro
y aura des gens n'y aura quasiment plus
oui à ça j'en suis sûr
deuxièmement deuxièmement cirque avec
des immigrés qui sont délinquants dont
louis en tout cas des immigrés ou des
enfants d'immigrés c'est bien français
ils seront alors jusqu'au mans va
traiter ça laissez moi finir deuxième
question deuxième question donc je
supprime le regroupement familial le
droit d'asile ne sera plus qu'une
poignée de gens qui seront et pas 130000
comme aujourd'hui les étudiants au
pareil les a toutes les sources de deux
des migrations gelé car un accord je
supprime la et me je supprime les ms
relations sociales non contributives aux
étrangers je supprime le droit du sol à
dire qu'on ne sera plus
français parce qu'on est nés en france
est ce que ça veut dire qu'il a du mal
quand même à sortir de ces thématiques
mais non il a pas de mal il a fait une
heure d'intervalle chez vous il a par
des l'immigration pendant 10 minutes et
effectivement oui est ce que je vous ai
dit tout à l'heure
on l'illustrent par notre propre
comportement donc et il a parlé de
l'année zaz
désindustrialisation de la france du
problème justement d'épouser une espèce
d'écologie
que la bien-pensance de l'époque nous
impose alors que on peut peut-être
concilier cela avec une
réindustrialisation et faire en sorte
que et de comprendre que la france est
un pollueur mineur par rapport à
à lachine la politique écologique qui
aurait affaibli la désertification des
territoires enfin des provinces parce
que les territoires je déteste ce mot
enfin oui beaucoup de choses à dire et
il parle de pendant dix minutes à raison
ça fait choc ça fait mais en gros
d'ailleurs ce qui est assez intéressant
c'est que ce qu'il dit sur la
délinquance
etc ses rapports avec l'immigration ou
avec les enfants de l'immigration parce
que ça y est c'est une réalité aussi eh
bien
ça domine sa domine tout poil as et
c'est exactement à venir sur la question
de l'écologie un dernier mot la thuringe
a vu on est fondamentalement d'accord il
ya deux biais si vous voulez dans cette
phrase la première c'est qu'en effet l
éclipse tout est donc à partir de là
vous avez des propositions qui sont
originales qui montrent justement cette
diversification est derrière cette
diversification tout un travail de
crédibilisation de la candidature qui du
coup ne sera probablement pas repris et
ensuite ça renvoie à d'autres propos
tous les trafiquants sont noirs et
arabes et cetera ces propos qui ont pu
faire polémique à l'époque qui ont fait
que eh bien vous avez une candidature
qui aujourd'hui pour beaucoup de
français y compris de droite sent le
souffre et ça eric zemmour pour le coup
et bien leur confirme et risquent de
tourner le dos à un électorat plus
modéré que pourtant il vise sa stratégie
d'union des droites implique certes
d'aller marcher sur les plates-bandes du
rassemblement national mais aussi des
républicains si vous prenez le dernier
buzz pour le monde vous voyez que la
grande porosité aujourd'hui du vote mme
pécresse l épave eric zemmour elle est
justement vers emmanuel macron parce que
cette candidature la part est
aujourd'hui trop radicales pour une
partie de cet électorat avec de telles
phrases ou le fait vous ne fait que
confirmer son intuition parce que ce qui
est important c'est le message de la fin
aussi c'est l'union des droites et il a
raison sur ceux de ce point de vue
depuis jacques chirac il n'y en a pas
beaucoup peut-être un petit peu nicolas
sarkozy qui a réussi à la faire mais
c'est tout en 2007 on réussit assez bien
aujourd'hui c'est on le voit c'est
d'ailleurs sa conclusion dire que elle
est tiraillée finalement parce qu'elle
n'arrive pas à remplir 7,7 c'est ce pari
là qui exige un langage qui est un
langage à la fois de fermeté et un
langage de pragmatisme et ils essayent
de tenir ça on va parler effectivement
delà de l'écologie puisque effectivement
il a beaucoup parlé il a beaucoup
critiqué en tout cas la politique d
écologie c'est la politique écolo prise
par emmanuel macron pour faire plaisir à
nicolas hulot c'est ce qu'il a dit il en
a parlé quand on l'interrogé sur le
pouvoir d'achat quand on l'interrogeait
sur le nucléaire quand on l'interrogeait
sur l'avenir de l'industrie automobile
et lui fait un lien entre entre le
déclin de ses industries et la politique
écologie oui il fait un lien et c'est un
lien alors
ne faut pas tout mélanger non plus c'est
à dire que est évidemment ce lien et
pratiques des commodes parce que il
permet d'expliquer beaucoup de choses il
faut pas non plus négliger le fait qu'il
faille est en faveur de la préservation
de l'environnement enfin c'est notre
avenir qui est en jeu aussi donc il faut
essayer de concilier de force est de
constater que cette conciliation
personne n'a réussi à la faire surtout
pas les écologistes qui sont des pisse
froid et qui je suis désolé mais qui
nous renvoie à un âge de pierre
que personne n'a envie de vivre ça veut
dire oui et donc
qui en plus détruisent d'une certaine
façon une partie de la croissance qui
est nécessaire et bien à la prospérité
du pays donc ce pari de conciliation n'a
été réussi par personne y compris par le
président et la majorité sortante
aujourd'hui qu'il sait c'est si vous
voulez tout le monde cherche le montre
awa actuellement à jamais ce que vous
êtes un peu moins dur avec les
écologistes qui vient je dirais pas que
ce sont des pisse-froid mais malgré tout
si vous voulez il faut reconnaître
[Rires]
mais ça peut marquer l'opinion c'est à
dire que quand il dit 1% des émissions
co2 est grave c'est pour le coup une
défense relativement intelligente qui
lui permet justement de ménager une
position qui n'est pas anti écologique
n'est pas
opposé à l'existence dû réchauffement
climatique mais qui en même temps peut
être pragmatique après ce qu on peut
sans doute lui reprocher c'est un manque
de vision par exemple sur la voiture
aujourd'hui on sait qu'on va vers une
voiture qui probablement va être tout
électrique d'ici quelques années la
question c'est comment est-ce qu'on
augmente le l'électricité le stock
d'électricité c'est un vrai problème
aujourd'hui sans polluer est donc là
pour le coup il faut un discours
peut-être sur le nucléaire où pouvait
avoir sur ces sujets là une écologique
est une écologie je dirais de conquête
en termes de technologie en termes de
production d'énergie on a des avantages
comparatifs qui peuvent être énormes
donc plutôt que de dire de manière très
conservatrice restons à ce qui est
aujourd'hui et prom ou
faisant la promotion du moteur diesel je
crois qu'ils avaient justement une
possibilité de marier
réindustrialisation d'un côté politique
écologique de l'autre ce qui permet de
doper les ventes ce qui permet de doper
l'économie et ce qui permet
accessoirement si on en juge que c'est
pas une priorité pour moi c'en est
plutôt une mais de faire baisser les
émissions de co2 il a eu un discours
quand même sur sur le nucléaire il a
fait une proposition il a rappelé qu'
qui va l'assurer que lui souhaitait
construire 14 réacteurs nucléaires
emmanuel macron s'en souvient en
novembre avait dit on y va on va
relancer le nucléaire en france on
attend toujours le chiffre précis inde
emmanuel macron sur la paix petit le
central les petits centrale est aussi
voilà de réactiver cette industrie
nucléaire on attend les chiffres précis
mais je suis pas certain que c'est ce
que qu'en allant sur ce terrain du
nucléaire ça suffisent à cliver par
rapport à emmanuel macron on voit bien
qu'un consensus paraît ce qu aujourd'hui
sur le nucléaire en tout cas du centre
jusqu'à la droite et l'extrême par
rapport à la droite également c'est à
dire que quand vous prenez le scénario
rte le problème c'est pas que on ne
veuille pas faire de nucléaire c'est que
au stade où on en est si jamais on
choisit le scénario maximum de rte on
peut pas en faire plus en réalité tout
bêtement parce que les acteurs de la
construction odf excédera ne peuvent pas
suivre le rythme donc on a un plat sans
nucléaire ce qui implique en réalité de
développer certaines énergies
renouvelables pas parce que on a envie
de faire des de l'éolien ou parce qu'on
a envie de faire du solaire parce qu'en
réalité au regard du mix climatique à ce
stade là pour des raisons très
pragmatiques on n'a pas le choix dany
aussi un truc intéressant alors
effectivement c'est un peu noyé dans ce
qu'on disait tout à l'heure quand il dit
qu'il veut rééquilibrer un peu le
rapport entre les villes et les
campagnes fait une proposition assez
forte et même oui voilà renversé
carrément la vapeur et c'est l'apport de
l'histoire parce qu'effectivement il
rappelle que cet équilibre entre les
villes et campagnes c'est un peu
inversée dans les années 30 il propose
de transférer les fonds de la politique
de la ville c'est environ 500 millions
d'euros 500 millions d'euros de la
politique de la ville vers les campagnes
il ya une explication à ça explique
qu'il a avec le décodeur il n'a pas été
dit non mais parce que eric zemmour si
vous reprenez son sens à sa vision des
choses depuis depuis quasiment toujours
c'est que il estime justement que
l'argent qui a été investi
dans la rénovation notamment de grandes
de ces grandes cités urbaines et tous a
souvent été de l'argent jeté par les
fenêtres parce que il n'a pas été fait
les résultats n'ont pas été au rendez
vous si vous voulez de ses
investissements qui ont été faits c'est
un discours de droite assez classique
d'ailleurs c'est de dire que cet argent
j'allais dire cet argent rocard au
salsero recrues car qui voulaient
repeindre les les cages d'escalier bon
ben ok mais ça n'a pas eu d'effet sûr et
bien
la délinquance sur la réduction de la
délinquance sur l'éducation des jeunes
sur l' autorité sur tout ça est donc cet
argent bas il faut savoir le réorienter
et c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui vous avez
les
les provinces et les zones rurales qui
sont touchés par la désertification des
services publics ça mais qui sont aussi
touchés par une certaine forme de
délinquance maintenant parce que cette
délinquance a gagné tous les tous les
espaces français et donc bah il veut
rééquilibrer
cette ces investissements qui sont faits
ça ça mérite d'être considérée justement
non je crois que l'idée alors les
propositions pelé discuter mais l'idée
en effet est bonne c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui on a un problème de sur
métropolisation ce qui pose tout un tas
de soucis en vanité souci d'équilibré
économique souci écologique également
c'est à dire que si jamais on veut
demain pensez à nouveau l'aménagement du
territoire il faut accepter que une
partie de la population se déplace vers
des zones aujourd'hui considéré comme
étant rural le problème c'est que c'est
pas qu un problème de politique de la
ville c'est un problème de tissu
économique comment est-ce qu'on crée de
l'emploi sur ces territoires donc c'est
un problème beaucoup plus large en
réalité ensuite déplacé les fonds de la
politique de la ville vers les zones
rurales j'avais c'est un peu un slogan
parce que dans la politique de la ville
vous avez certes au raid normand aubin
et on sait qu'il a échoué vous avez
également le développement de services
publics or le service public par
habitant est plus faible dans ces zones
qu'il n'est qu'il n'existe en zone
rurale en réalité où le gros problème
n'est pas le nom de l'habitant mais
l'espace dans la politique de la ville
vous avez également la politique
éducative dans la politique de la ville
vous avez la politique économique pour
donner justement du tissu économique à
ces territoires pour que les gens
n'aient pas à bouger vers les
centres-villes et pour arriver justement
que affaires qu'il puisse y avoir une
intégration sur ces territoires là donc
en soi la politique de la ville en
transférer les fonds c'est un faux
problème c'est un peu un slogan même si
l'idée originale et plutôt bonne un
dernier mot sur un sujet dont on parle
beaucoup ici et sur lequel on entend des
mois eric zemmour c'est lé maire lui
veut donner plus de compétences les
maires il dit que les maires n'ont pas
assez de compétences et qu'il faut
donner plus de compétences au maire
alors ça c'est un un vieux sujet sur ces
histoires de la compétence générale des
maires notamment et puis sur les
pouvoirs de police des mers aussi bon
les maires ont des pouvoirs de police
sauf le maire de paris qui a moins de
pouvoir que les autres oui on peut
revoir effectivement le périmètre mais
si si vous voulez si vous revoyez le
périmètre de compétence des élus il faut
revoir le périmètre de compétence de
tous les élus parce que ça fait partie
aussi de cette politique qui consiste et
bien justement à
le millefeuille qui est mille fois
dénoncé dans notre pays dans le mille
feuille territorial et bien il est ils
concernent principalement aussi les
compétences des uns et des autres et
d'ailleurs quand on lui pose la question
sur ce millefeuille territorial il dit
pas de big bang les élus veulent pas de
big bang et il nous dit pas clairement
s'il veut supprimer des strates en
supplie mais c'est un peu le problème si
vous voulez parce que son analyse à
l'origine des bonnes c'est à dire que ce
qui le diagnostic est fait de la
décentralisation apparaît très juste on
a dit la décentralisation est un moyen
de démocratiser l'action publique mais
on a vidé l'échelon principal auquel
s'identifie les français c'est à dire la
commune on a multiplié les échelons de
plus en plus large de plus en plus
grands est ce qu'il est vraiment
pertinent d'administrer le cantal depuis
lyon est ce que c'est vraiment plus
proche que paris n'est pas tout à fait
évident qu'aujourd'hui la région par
exemple soit un échelon de proximité et
de l'autre côté est bien en vie dans
l'échelon de base l'échelon communal de
ses compétences de ses capacités d'agir
on a tué la démocratie locale et ensuite
on s'étonne que de l'abstention mais non
en réalité c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui
les français ne complète ne comprennent
plus cette structure et ne s'y
reconnaissent plus non plus donc il faut
arriver justement à repenser une refonte
à redonner du pouvoir aux niveaux ultra
local c'est-à-dire au niveau communal et
peut-être au niveau départemental et
simplifier le millefeuille pour arriver
justement à créer un sentiment
d'identification ça si vous êtes dans
une position conservatrice comme les
emmanuel macron comme l'est aujourd'hui
eric zemmour en disant c'est trop
complexe on n'y touche pas évidemment
vous empêchez en réalité la réforme qui
serait nécessaire
[Musique]